Thanksgiving has come and gone which
means we are officially in the holiday
season the most wonderful time of the
year that's what the song says and I
think this year there is something that
we can all do that maybe we don't all do
that often and certainly if you live in
the online world that I talk a lot about
and I live often in it that we could all
be a little better about is taking some
of that holiday spirit the season spirit
and what it's all supposed to be about
uh you know sharing and love and all
that good stuff uh and just toning down
the rhetoric in every way whatsoever
right like I'm not just talking about
the people you're fighting with online
and all your political enemies and the
the guy that lives next door to you
whose dogs been taking a [ __ ] on your
lawn that I'm seriously pissed I don't
know what we can do about this guy uh
but everybody the family members
everybody I think maybe I what I like
about this time of year is we got like a
little it basically a month a little bit
more five weeks between Thanksgiving and
the new years where maybe we could all
try to have that spirit a little bit
more cuz I feel like we have so little
of that in this country you know it i
mean like we go right from thanksgiving
to bestbuy where you're pushing an old
lady down an escalator to get a
flat-screen TV we just immediately
forget what it's all about and we could
take the spirit of the holiday season
and take a little break from the endless
back and forth right left uh you know
partisan bickering that we're all doing
and maybe if someone doesn't agree with
you instead of yelling at them and
attacking them retweeting them with some
snarky comment uh maybe sort of be you
know oh well we don't agree on
everything but we're still humans and
maybe there's a little room that we can
that we can work with here and and
realize that there's room to to talk and
to grow and all that good stuff so I'm
gonna certainly try that this holiday
season I try it in general but I think
now with with the Christmas music I
think I'm gonna try a little bit more uh
and I hope that I hope that you guys
will try to because it's not it look we
get endless endless parade of nonsense
right we all know that we all know that
the news is always going to be crazy in
the world is always going to be upside
I don't know he seems worse than it is
but I think now let's try it for a
couple weeks then and then back to New
Year's will go crazy again